thank you
Sub-Zero
Kano Kano
game mansion
your actions cost lies behind they were
in the linquay's best interests
I've learned your secret have the others
is that the linkway's new tactic
extortion
your clan used to serve a noble cause it
is better now that we serve ourselves
oh
ever battle a blind swordsman
you aren't the first Takahashi
your war on the underworld is taking
innocent lives am I to blame for my
enemies wanting violence
keep Countess Jade close
she is critical to your future is
tick
I've been looking forward to this fight
you enjoy losing that much Earth realmer
you will not enter the Temple of the
elements I will have the power you've
locked away inside
thank you